je sais que c'est difficile mais je dois
vous poser les questions sur ce qui
s'est passé
il m'a d'abord attaché libre
il a dit que si jamais je criais ils me
tueraient aucun signe d'effraction les
portes et fenêtres étaient fermées à clé
pas de traces adn absolument aucun
voisin a vu ou entendu quoi que ce soit
l'agresseur avait de quoi la bâillonner
mais rien pour l'attacher délasser
aurait suffi à l'immobiliser mari a tout
inventé
je suis à peu près sûr qu'un homme
avions à peu près sûrs ou complètement
sûr il me poser les mêmes questions il
tient pas la route votre histoire je
voulais partir rentrer chez moi il n'y a
aucune des teams ici c'était du vent
elle a tout inventé
[Musique]
je trouve sur les lieux de cette
violente agression qui selon la police
un homme masqué et armé d'un couteau ce
serait donc introduit chez sa victime
alors que cette dernière dormait il a
dit tu devrais faire plus attention à ta
sécurité
un masque noir des liens agression petit
matin je pense pas être la première
à aurora il y a dix huit mois un intrus
masque noir et sac à dos ils l'attachent
prend des photos et jusqu'à maintenant
ils courent toujours
on comprend le schéma un viol est commis
ils ont des preuves de nouveaux indices
et puis c'est la petit à petit ils
trouvent plus rien jusqu'à ce qu'il
récidive il vaut mieux qu on se démerde
tout seul
et s'ils savaient tout ça que les
stations ne communiquent pas entre elles
tant qu'ils ne frappent qu'une seule
fois dans chaque district il peut y
avoir des inspecteurs de huit
départements différents qui enquêtent
chacun dans leur coin sur huit viols
similaires sans se douter un instant
qu'ils recherchent tous le même
le violeur n'agit pas dans un périmètre
défini h couleur de peau ses victimes
n'ont pas de profil particulier elle dit
tout seul
ce gars est là dehors dans la nature
prêt à jeter son dévolu sur la femme la
plus vulnérable qui trouvera pourquoi
n'est-il pas choquer
c'est quelque chose qu'elles ont gardé
en haine toute leur vie c'est un fardeau
que de vous porter
[Musique]
même les personnes à qui on croit
pouvoir faire confiance si la vérité
correspond pas à ce qui les arrange
elles veulent pas moi